hello fellow lovers of Jesus and God and
atheists welcome to our channel my name
is Ryan right there are a lot of other
it boils down to just those couple
though at the end of the day okay if you
worship Gandhi
she's Lauren ya silly you just sounded
hey guys I'm Lauren God okay so we're
gonna watch the trailer
speaking of religion alien abduction
there's a lot of people think that the
aliens are religious yeah Scientologists
Scientologists believe that yeah
Scientologists believe that we inhabit
our own world or something like that
afterwards all I know is Tom Cruise
leaves it so I'm gonna believe it too
anyway guys alien abduction don't know
what it's about soon has something to do
with being a doctor actions
it's a found footage site by horror
movie oh how exciting
I like all of those things I'm I know I
mean so it's a Catholic independent film
it looks like it's all fun but it's not
stick together 16 like no matter what
happens we love each other
no whoa
hundreds of residents of reporting
strange light
some accident Chinese people they might
have left the car so those are the
dampers why are there so many burdens
above them all even the recording all
this lot because the first thing I'm
gonna do when I'm like running for my
life is to
nowhere to hide
do this looks terrifying
it's my last shot of the movie okay
that was creepy as [ __ ] that looks cool
man I usually don't like found-footage
horror movies actually hate horror
movies because I don't like to be scared
that one looked cool because I actually
want to know more about the what it was
based on this round lights at South
Carolina whatever they said it was yeah
that's really cool the fact that you're
doing a found footage movie about an
alien abduction I mean just that concept
you hear it I could see why Hollywood
was like we got to make that movie yeah
I mean it's cool as most alien abduction
movies have like a fun science fiction
vibe about it this actually has like
what if this really happened yeah it
might be some scary ass [ __ ] going on I
feel like they're gonna capture that
tone very well I hope it's not like
annoying found footage that were like
seriously yeah well I I get no just
shouldn't sec yeah like Blair Witch
Project if you were throwing up in the
aisles like that that would be mean that
person would be me so you get nauseous
II gagged
I don't gag like I've never actually
thrown up from motion sickness since I
was a little girl I threw up once after
a gondola ride that maybe I should say
so how are your gagging reflexes I don't
throw up on people when I get [ __ ]
that's what we print never going with
that take well guys thanks for
recommending that trailer you're all
awesome for recommending that I have
been avoiding that try that for a while
because it just didn't sound that
intriguing to me but it was a cool trip
I wish I watched this earlier and more
suggestions on the basic page for what
trailers you think we should review yes
plug that Facebook Lauren follow the
rejects on Instagram and Twitter yeah
yeah you could week to us hey I'm on the
toilet or whatever your [ __ ] you guys I
mean it I also have an Instagram on
Twitter if you want to follow me too you
can follow Lord I'm Instagram button and
Ryan Wright has his own on Twitter as
well you should use it more alright guys
if you're new to the channel mm-hmm
that's me with the subscribe in the
alien abduction Oh
I like the better when alien abductions
were done with a beam yeah and there was
like a cow that's good yeah hey whoa
can you meet this guy button a cow no
stop with the weird scrub and you act so
mcCormick you wanted a shout-out so you
should go buy some equipment
anyway Adria that's how you get special
shout out and cow / alien voice you're
welcome
good yeah a good time nice mocha steer
and have a good night Christian Buress
briseida Christian Reseda
I'll stop that's a night no wasn't a
Christian thanks for watching thanks for
watching Christian dude cool [ __ ]
name Christian it looks like your new
should be barista yeah I was thinking
that too you be a good barista by the
way shouldn't barista who's that barista
over there Christian he's a good barista
that kid thumb I said what's up sup so
that's Christian right now texting us
that's right we might want on silent as
long as we give our subscribers our
phone number is there
oh is blowing up GM Patrick check some
menthe a GN Patrick some Monday wassup
San your how are you why are you being
lat I don't know that's what it sounded
like
I don't think some monta is a
classically a lot name is it what
ethnicity are you Gian reply right now
we're waiting we're gonna keep recording
until you hear us meaning we give it up
yeah subscribe
oh my god who's at the door